Mr Speaker I know the house will join
the nation and the Commonwealth and
sending our very best wishes to their
majesties the king and queen
[Applause]
[Music]
there'll be a moment of extraordinary
national pride a demonstration of our
country's character and an opportunity
to look to the Future in the spirit of
service unity and hope Mr Speaker this
morning I had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others in addition to my
duties in this house I shall have
further such meetings later today
at took question time last week column
725 the Prime Minister referred to
record numbers of people in work
fact as he knows the number of people in
work at the moment are still less than
it was just before the pandemic 122
792 less according to the latest
official figures will he reassure the
house that he's not slipping into the
bad ways of his predecessor but one
and will he properly correct the
incorrect statement he made last week
Mr Speaker that clarification has
already been made uh Mr Speaker in
Hansard but there are near record
numbers of people in work and in payroll
and that is thanks that is thanks to the
actions of this government Mr Speaker
one record we're very proud of
very much Mr Speaker I'm non-compliant
hand car washes seem like a cheap and
quick way to have our cars washed but
unfortunately behind this 1.8 billion
pound industry is hidden money
laundering fraud drug dealing
prostitution labor abuse modern day
slavery tax avoidance and many other
Sinister crimes
um this is an estimated half a billion
pound lost in tax revenue a pull factor
for illegal migration and the pollutants
often news are damaging to the
environment does the Prime Minister
agree with me but it's time that we now
step away from the voluntary scheme and
have a mandatory scheme to protect
people
well Mr Speaker we expect all businesses
to follow the law including providing
Fair pay and working conditions for
their employees we're tackling
exploitation in the labor market
especially by increasing funding for
enforcement bodies to over 35 million
pounds a year and we will continue to
keep the position of hand car washes
under close review but how come the
leader of the opposition give Starbucks
thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
prime minister in his comments about the
coronation across the house we're all
looking forward to the celebrations this
weekend
Mr Speaker does the Prime Minister know
how many mortgage payers are paying
higher rates since the Tory party
crashed the economy last autumn
well Mr Mr Speaker our record our record
on home ownership is crystal clear
because of our tax cuts 90 of first-time
buyers now don't pay any stamp duty at
all
[Applause]
and last year we saw the largest number
of people buying their first home in 20
years Mr Speaker that's the conservative
government delivering on people's
aspirations to own their own home
Mr Speaker the question was how many
people are paying more on their
mortgages each month and the answer that
the Prime Minister avoided giving is 850
000. nearly a million people paying more
on their mortgage each month because his
party used their money as a casino chip
that's why George Osborne called them
economic vandals who created a
self-inflicted financial crisis
not not for the Prime Minister and his
non-dom thing
not for the super wealthy they gave tax
cuts to but for mortgage holders all
across the country
so does the Prime Minister know how many
more people will be joining them on
higher mortgage rates by the end of this
year
Mr well Mr Mr Speaker thanks to the
actions we're taking in Flack The Bank
of England is showing that public
expectations of inflation have now eased
to a 15-month low Mr Speaker consumer
confidence is at the highest level that
it's been at since Russia invaded
Ukraine and because of our stewardship
of the public finances we can see a
clear way to reduce debt and bring
interest rates down but Mr Speaker he
keeps in this habit of quoting the
former labor Shadow chances we know that
our plans will deliver lower inflation
and lower interest rates but we know we
know that his plans his plans just mean
more debt Mr Speaker and I quote and I
quote year after year after year those
aren't my words that's the assessment of
the former labor Shadow Chancellor
Mr Speaker the question was how many
more people this year going to be paying
more on their mortgages
and the answer that he avoided giving
again he knows these answers he's got
the stats there in front of him 930
000 people so by the end of the this
year I know they don't want to talk
about it that's why he won't answer the
questions by the end of this year nearly
2 million homeowners counting the cost
of the tourist economic vandalism with
every mortgage payment they make and
it's not just those who already own
their home that are counting the cost of
Tory recklessness the average deposit
for a first-time buyer is going up to 9
000 pounds
does he even know how long it would take
an average saver to put that sort of
money aside
we've introduced a 95 mortgage guarantee
scheme Mr Speaker it's why we're helping
people in social housing own their own
home through our first homes and our
shared home ownership schemes but Mr
Speaker I said I said these things are
working because I said last year we had
a record number of first-time buyers the
highest number in 20 years it was Mr
Speaker twice the number of first-time
buyers then labor ever managed Mr
Speaker so whilst labor failed
homeowners the conservatives are
delivering for them
[Music]
country and every week he does so he
reinforces just how out of touch he is
nine thousand pounds hahaha nine
thousand pounds would take four years
they think it's funny that hope nine
four years four years for the average
saver to save nine thousand pounds or or
to put it a different way in terms the
Prime Minister will understand roughly
the annual Bill to heat his swimming
pool
four more years of scrimping it's a
hammer blow to their ambitions
are now who's kicking them when they're
down because his decision to scrap
housing targets is killing the dream of
home ownership for a generation why
doesn't admit he got it wrong and
reverse it
[Applause]
promised to put
Patrol of new housing and I'm proud that
that's what I delivered within six weeks
of becoming prime minister now he wants
to impose top-down housing targets he
wants a concrete over the green belt and
ride roughshod over local communities
now previously Mr Speaker he did say
he's on record and saying local people
local communities should have more power
more control now he's U-turn just
another in a long list of broken
promises
Mr Speaker the only Power he's given to
local communities not to build houses
and we know why he won't change course
he admitted it last month his counselors
simply don't want to build the houses
local people need so he's given them a
way out
picture of the scene as he explains this
to a family mum and dad paying four
grand extra on the mortgage because the
tourists tanked the economy their eldest
paying hundreds more in rent their
youngest still stuck in the spare room
because they need an extra 9 000 pounds
for a deposit so then along times the
Prime Minister unmarily tells them
sorry for Clash of the economy we don't
want to talk about that
sorry I can't help you with the house
building but my counselor
before I go here's a massive council tax
increase for your troubles while that's
nice stop the excuses stop blaming
everyone else I just build some houses
instead